bonjour patrice clos merci d'être avec
nous sur arte france alors est-ce que
les perspectives d'une pénurie
alimentaire sont elles vraiment réel
selon vous en france non au jour
d'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de risque pas
y avoir de pénurie il n'y a pas de
problème qu'on réalimenter les managers
et partout en france il ya aucun souci
là-dessus après la ruée vers les denrées
de base à l'aube du confinement mais
vous le sentiment que les français se
sont responsabilisés dans leurs achats
alimentaires ou au contraire pas du tout
ils ont fait des stocks donc un moment
donné c'est bien de faire des stocks
mais après il faut utiliser mais il n'y
a aucun problème aujourd'hui sur
l'approvisionnement et le
réapprovisionnement au niveau des
supermarchés ou autre
madeleine d'un évident à titre personnel
vous représentez le secteur des
transports quelles sont les difficultés
majeures que les transporteurs rencontre
dans le réapprovisionnement des
enseignes de distribuer de distribution
alimentaire elle est problématique c'est
que il ya eu la fermeture des
restaurants ont donc tous les
restaurants goûter offert mais ceux des
autres routes aussi et les salariés ne
pouvaient pas je pouvais pas vrai j'ai
ils pouvaient pas aller aux sanitaires
ils pouvaient pas prenez lellouche
donc il a fallu un peu énervé un peu le
gouvernement pour que ça cesse parce que
c'était pas possible pour les salariés
du transport routier
alors quand vous avez fait justement
pour interpeller le gouvernement pour
pour faire parvenir vos revendications
au gouvernement d' emmanuel macron mais
les lundis où il ya eu la fermeture du
restaurant a tapé du poing sur la table
sera pas suffi de mardi on a continué le
mercredi fn
le secrétaire d'état aux transports ça
nage a pas d'un décret qui a été fait le
jeudi mais dans les faits entre paris et
ce qui se passe sur le terrain c'est
assez long donc le vendredi soir on a
demandé aux salariés du transport qui
était considéré pire que des déchets de
faire un droit de retrait parce qu'à
exercer leur métier dans ces
conditions-là déjà que c'est difficile
ce n'était pas acceptable et il ya un
problème qui va se poser justement si
vous exercez votre droit de retrait y
aura plus de réapprovisionnement pour
les pour les chaînes de grande
distribution alimentaire qui est la
meilleure stratégie à adopter
le droit de retrait c'était juste sur
les produits non essentiels c'est pas
sûr sur le produit que les produits
essentiels tels que par dürer
alimentaire ou ski ce qu'il faut pour
par exemple transporter les masques
faire les vasques aussi ça c'est ilan
est pas question bien évidemment mais il
est hors de question que les salariés
transports notamment les routiers soient
jetés en pâture sur la route
s'il n'a pas les structures derrière
moment donné ça ne peut pas le faire
pour vous qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce
qui va être nécessaire pour gouvernants
pour répondre aux besoins alimentaires
de la population cette période de crise
ben moi je pense qu'il faut être une
conne se limite aux transports est
essentielle parce que vous donnez la
ressource en tant que conducteur voit va
aussi s'affaiblir puisque certains
d'entre eux sont déjà malades par le
virus
et si on n'y fait pas attention
si à cinquante pour ça nous connectera -
déjà qu'on est en pénurie de conducteurs
en temps normal si on n'y fait pas
attention il y aura aussi une pénurie du
conducteur qui va engendrer derrière une
pénurie de livraison et du coup une
pénurie alimentaire pour les français
c'est un cercle vicieux
oui tout à fait merci beaucoup pour tout
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général fo
transports